[Music]
hello welcome to dear Hank and John or
as I prefer to think of it Dear John and
Hank it's a colony podcast where me and
my brother John answer your questions
give me to be as advice and bring you
all the week's news from both Mars and
AFC Wimbledon and today we're doing it
live together that's right we are both
right now in New York City why are we in
New York Hank we're doing a thing with
Save the Children we are going to a gala
this evening or possibly a gala or
possibly a gala at which we are being
feted or possibly feeded for whatever
for very dubious contributions to the
field of making the world suck less yeah
I am I I keep people ask me why I'm
going to New York and I'm like I'm doing
a thing with Save the Children because I
feel very awkward about saying what they
say that I'm doing the truth is that we
are receiving an award but we find the
awarding of this award to be completely
ludicrous and so the greater truth is
that we have been asked to do something
might save the children and we were
happy to say yes we do not generally say
no when they ask us to do stuff so
today's podcast is going to be a little
bit different in two ways first off Hank
and I are both here together that's nice
secondly it's gonna be of much lower
quality because we have very little time
before we have to put on our extremely
fancy suits it is true there is you may
some here some jackhammering in the
background that's because it's New York
City you guys yep here is New York that
were the jackhammers never stopped they
are making things that is actually do
you know that's what they say they say
it's the city that never sleeps due to
the 24/7 jackhammering I believe that's
the phrase started this morning at
around 8:00 which isn't so bad
so hey let me ask you real quickly how
are you doing I'm good I'm a little bit
stressed because it's it's Pizza mess
yes and I need to make a podcast today
and also a video and also go to a gala
gala gah-la should we move directly in
to the short poem of the day in that
case sure Hank I would like to tell you
something that is deeply true
I do not have a short man today okay
well that wellwe've that was a really
beautiful poem job thank you let's move
on to the next portion I'm gonna I'm
gonna find a poem Hank while we are
talking but um I really I've already
read that Margaret Atwood poem that I
usually use in times of crisis
you've got doing any times of Christ oh
okay we'll use this Dorothy Parker poem
unfortunate coincidence okay I have a
list of short poems on my phone in case
of emergency and we are in one so we're
gonna use this Dorothy Parker poem
unfortunate coincidence by the time you
swear you're his shivering and sighing
and he vows his passion is infinite
undying lady make a note of this one of
you is lying oh dang Dorothy Parker
unfortunate coincidence so let's move on
now to questions from our readers while
Hank is looking up the news from Mars do
some questions Johnny can hear you
clicking away I can't keyboard again it
would have been fine if you had just
kept quiet all right Hank this question
is from Jeff it's vitally important Dear
John and a Hank I just came from the
dentist and why do dental hygienists
want to carry on conversations with you
while they are scraping away at your
teeth it's not like I can answer with
your hands in my mouth I suggest if you
must talk keep the questions to yes or
no ones and I will give a thumbs up or
thumbs down to indicate my answer well
here again we have come to dear Hank and
John with questions John is qualified to
answer John a man who has had many
people's hands inside of his mouth so
many I don't know that there is a person
on earth who has had more strangers
insert gloved hands into his mouth than
myself so here is my theory I've had
great dental hygienists and I've had
terrible ones and I've had ones in the
middle the first thing that I look for
in a dental hygienist is are they expert
at removing plaque without hurting me
unnecessarily which is a real talent
and a real skill the second thing I look
for is are they able to deliver 20 to 30
minute long monologues without needing
any input from me that will be of
interest to me so for instance my
current dental hygienist who's just
brilliant is both excellent at the
plaque scraping and wonderfully talented
when it comes to I sit down she says so
I saw the Paper Towns movie and then
proceeds to talk for 20 minutes in a
very interesting way about all the
strengths and weaknesses she feels we're
in the Paper Towns movie and then when
the whole thing is over I can respond
right so it's just a different kind of
conversation I have a question for you
yes what what is this person's job title
again dental hygienist hygienist
hygienist dental hygienic what is this
person's job said it's no no T there's
no teeth I've been saying like this hey
I do do you have good dental hygiene
I do I have excellent dental hygienist
now I didn't in my teens and while I'm
in this mess in the first place dental
hygienist dental hygienist dental
hygienist dental hygienist I want to say
test yeah he and dentist that's not then
Dennis it's not just Dennis if that your
friend the dentist my friend my friend
my friend Dennis who is a hygienist
that's how I'll remember it okay I'm
glad I'm glad we could we also a little
more information for you there Jeff call
it call them a dental hygienist and they
might respect you more to be fair in his
question Jeff did call him a dental
hygienist it's all on me not on Jeff and
I think that people just want it like
they're bored they don't want to just
great teeth all day they also want to
interact with humans yeah you have to
imagine your dental hygienist complexly
and understand that you know what they
want to have a social interaction and
also they want you to be as comfortable
as possible and I think that's a lot of
it like it's not comfortable when
someone is both scraping away at your
teeth and doing so silently because that
feels like a threat it's important I
agree John we have another question this
one is from Bethany who asks dear Hank
and John my question is why
you think our culture is so obsessed
with zombies well Bethenny I don't know
what Hanks answer is gonna be but this
is mine
let me submit to you that I am not
entirely sure who is running the show
inside my brain why do I want granite
countertops in my kitchen mmm why is it
because I am in fact kind of similar to
a zombie is it because I am also not
making conscious decisions is it because
I am also sort of making the default
choice because I don't really ultimately
have control over my consciousness but
in fact a cog in a much larger machine
that makes me think that maybe we write
about zombies because we fear that we
are zombies I think we write about
zombies and think about zombies because
the you know in in the history of
humanity the scariest things have tended
to be the things that kill us and we are
usually killed by you know a as as
humans humans get killed by disease
microbes mostly microbes yeah nowadays
if your theory were correct let me argue
if your theory were correct all of them
you haven't heard my theory I know what
you're gonna be which is that the zombie
is the person is like a is like a like a
monster ization of disease instead of
disease being this invisible cloud that
is everywhere and and like any like you
accidentally walk into it it is a
disease that attacks you physically and
that the disease is transmitted through
violent acts Todd unfortunately I love
that theory I'm so ready
disagree with you but I think that's
brilliant because I think I think that
what I III think that we are all afraid
of disease but we find it very difficult
to personify disease movies about
diseases are scary but they're not like
horror or scary they're psychologically
scary yeah so you might have noticed by
the way that Katherine just turned the
shower off
now so there's less background noise
we're doing this in record time yeah
this is uh yeah so if it just got
quieter that's because the shower has
ended we're not in the bathroom with
Katherine to be clear not in the next
room yeah there's a separate thing but
you know okay
shares the wall okay point being disease
is something that we have a very
difficult time like both personifying
but also like actually like
comprehending because like our human
narrative memories and and ways of
processing the world want to tell us
that all the threats to us are the ones
that we fear the most that the biggest
threats are the ones that we fear the
most so for instance people are very
afraid of dying by violence even though
that is extremely unlikely or at least
in the vast majority of places in the
world it's extremely unlikely and people
are not adequately afraid of dying from
texting while driving right even though
that is one of the biggest threats to
your life so what we should what what
you're saying is the next big thing will
be the personification of texting while
driving
yes physically attacking and ripping
apart teenagers in movies oh my god what
a great idea not only have we discovered
Jurassic Mars the single greatest movie
idea of all time we've now discovered
the second greatest movie of all time a
horror movie about texting while driving
don't text while driving and if you're
listening to this in the car right now
friends and you're texting
oh god that's just it's too much Hank I
have forgotten that we have had an
amazing amazing development Oh which is
that I know why bananas are hexagonal or
as I like to say hex egg did know
hexagonal yeah so we got a tweet from
somebody explaining to us what why
bananas are hexagonal yeah I just got to
find it
where's my like tweets how do you find
the tweets the likes it's right there
okay so this is from brilliant botany
who seems like an expert based on their
Twitter handle let me see if I can find
out anything
it's a blog about the amazing world of
plants and how we study them total
expert brilliant botany at brilliant
botany check them out on Twitter writes
to answer the banana shaped question it
has to do with the shape of the banana
flower ovary
this makes yes this is good the banana
ovary has three locals chambers with two
lines of ovules in each three times two
equals six
aka a hexagon that's amazing so isn't it
isn't anything to do with the
functionality the banana only that the
it's just sort of an artifact of what
the banana once was like when it was
before it was a banana it's an artifact
of the shape of the flower oh yeah
that's really cool that is pretty cool
but it makes sense because that's what
if that's what the banana comes out of
yeah the banana is sort of forced as I
imagine it through
you may now hear a hairdryer through the
flower right
I don't know exhibit comes out of the
flower vagina ask brilliant button yeah
yeah brilliant botany on Twitter for all
your questions about banana shapes but I
will often get people who are like what
is the evolutionary reason why X yeah
and sometimes there isn't sometimes it's
just like this is how things happened
and we're stuck like the evolutionary
reason like why we have two arms and two
legs instead of like an extra like an
extra set of arms is just because like
the first thing that was the common
ancestor of all mammals had you know
these sort of two little thin things in
front and it had a little thing and back
and eventually like every that way all
mammals and birds and reptiles like all
like vertebrates have things were fish
411 or limbs I've always wanted to have
six limbs like Goro forearms like Goro
and Mortal Kombat was that his name just
just checking yep you hear any typing
it's because yeah we were right he's
doing live research live research here
on dear Hank and John okay I want to do
a couple like that bothers me about Goro
is that he has two sets of arms but only
one set of tectorial muscles
um so I'm not exactly sure how that
works right like how does he move the
bottom arms yeah to be fair though as I
recall he wasn't a particularly
effective villain on more at least in
mortal combat
which was the one I played a lot and
also when I say played a lot I should
also say play a lot because now we have
this stand-up arcade machine in our
office which is a lot and I enjoy
playing the Mortal Kombat I love playing
NBA Jam I'm really dating myself here
Hank but remember NBA Jam nope ok double
dribble it was after double dribble
you've just dated yourself tremendously
no one who listens to this podcast was
even alive
no so NBA Jam it was 2 on 2 and remember
it was like amazing dunks they could do
like ok it's been while dunking and then
they would dunk and then the announcer
would always be like abracadabra
yeah whatever um there's actually an
account you can follow on Twitter I
think it's it's an NBA Jam account and
just occasionally it tweets one of the
things that the announcer would say when
someone dunked on NBA Jam that's that's
its entire as a Twitter all right let's
answer another question from a reader a
viewer this one is from Grell from
kyrgyzstan that's the good question I
want to get to at the very end well you
want to ask is such a good question I
was to get to it as quick as possible
but I guess we'll skip that one from now
we'll get back to girls question at the
end this one is from Sean who asks dear
Hank and John for our second anniversary
my girlfriend has taken me to Wales in
the UK for the Doctor Who experience
where I will get to be on the set of
David Tennant's TARDIS I don't know how
to beat her idea for our anniversary so
do you guys have any suggestions for a
gift or anything I need help
it's in two weeks smiley face well Sean
first I say this isn't a competition
you guys are you just want to make the
other person happy not make the other
person less feel less good about your
gift because yours is better than theirs
right exactly if you then you get into
an arms race right and this did not work
for the Soviet Union Sean so I don't
think that it's going to work for you
you don't want to keep raising the
stakes of birthday presents Hank and I
did that the first few years on
vlogbrothers I became a disaster it was
a disaster by the end of it it was like
okay so I've created 48 hours of work
for myself yeah did little was wonderful
was nice it was rate of the thing
we had that we had to call an end to the
war it was time it had become a kind of
war where I hated Hank for having
birthdays the problem and I couldn't
even really enjoy the gifts that he
would get for me because I would just be
like well this means that I have to do
something extraordinary now secondly
Sean I'm a little concerned that you've
waited until two weeks out to begin
considering this two-year anniversary
present my rule with anniversaries is
that you begin considering it the number
of months before the anniversary it is
well that only works up to a certain
point because no no no what about your
what about your 57th it works all the
way up 57 months before I feel like 60
months before your 60th anniversary
mayor you can do that but not before
your 59th because you know you're gonna
be working so hard on the sixtieth
anyway the crazy thing is that at some
point you're working on like 20 or 30
different anniversaries at once this is
true you know the owners of math problem
I'm not a mathematician but but
according to my strategy at some point I
will be working on more than one
anniversary at a time very fairly soon
um well yeah right now so maybe the
alternative is terrible what does it
take 13 years before you're working on
yeah okay so anyway we've only been
married for nine years now my strategy
still works great anyway Sean long story
short you've waited too long just give
up yeah I think what you want to do is
pretend like that this is an anniversary
present your girlfriend is getting for
both of you yeah there's being like this
is this isn't the gift you're giving to
me it is an experience we are having
together and then take her out to a nice
doctor who themed dinner yeah maybe a
doctor who themed dinner unless she
doesn't care about Doctor Who at all
just take her that's what something that
she loves to do in Wales so let me tell
you some stuff that they do in Wales
never been there myself but I have I do
know them by reputation and I watch a
lot of Welsh soccer because that's where
Swansea City plays due to that being
where Swansea is also Cardiff City I
watch a lot of Welsh soccer come to
think of it so anyway take her to a
Swansea City game
they're right absent a seem to enjoy
that well you don't want Shawn I can't
help it well I've got a question for you
if you're going to Wales in the UK that
implies that you don't currently live in
the UK which means that you're probably
flying to Wales probably gonna take a
train from if he's not in the UK yeah he
probably is going to fly he's not me not
in the I figured he was from no no no
taking me to Wales in the UK implies
that he's on the UK yeah so they're
probably going to fly to London where
AFC Wimbledon plays oh my gosh we've
done it Sean don't do it AFC Wimbledon
game it's so nice to be here with you in
person so we could say that in unison
because our phone is when we're doing
this off it's like there's this like
three-second delay and it makes
everything impossible
oh you're going to an AFC Wimbledon game
Sean's partner whether you like it or
not happy anniversary
I'll even get you the tickets they're 10
bucks gosh okay we need to do one more
question before we get to the question
from Grail from pack from Kyrgyzstan
which I'm so excited about girls
question um katie has a question that
I'd quite like I wanted to answer Will's
question okay well let you let's do you
could do well okay there's like eight
thousand Katie's out there who are like
oh it wasn't you I wasn't you it was a
different Katie I don't know if you have
that if we have that many listeners
actually Nick you might've exaggerated
then we don't have an abundance of
katherines oh okay
this question is from Will who writes
Dear John and Hank I've been a supporter
of AFC Wimbledon since listening to this
podcast that's a great reason to start
and a great time to start however I
recently learned that one of my absolute
favorite podcasts ever for economics
also supports and sponsors in English
these football teams the mighty done cow
football club I can't seem to find any
information on whether AFC Wimbledon and
Dunn care will be direct competitors
because I'd hate to have to pick and I'm
not sure what I would do is this
something I should worry about it is
something you should worry about because
it implies that dear Hank and John might
be your second favorite podcast and
that's a guess around me another concern
is that freakanomics potentially stole
our idea yeah I'm a little concerned
that freakanomics did plagiarized us
would be I mean frankly what are the
odds that why would this idea happen
twice it is a dumb idea yeah so it
should not not be something that
happened to tons so if I were you I
would not be terribly concerned I'm
looking up right now and we're we're
precisely done cow FC is in in the world
it does not seem that they are very
likely to ever ever ever play AFC
Wimbledon here's a couple of reasons
they are a Sunday football team they
play it there like a Sunday week team
which means that they're probably below
the 9th division hmm so they'd have to
go away thanks Promotions
yeah so either the earliest AFC
Wimbledon could play Dunn County FC I
think is in three years if AFC Wimbledon
were relegated in three consecutive
years and done calves were promoted in
three consecutive years that seems very
unlikely to me yes because ANSI
Wimbledon is ninth in there leave it oh
that's such great news I don't want to
get ahead of myself but yes I think
you're okay I don't think Dunn cow is
ever going to play AFC Wimbledon if they
do it will be a big moment for us though
because we will find out if will prefers
Freakonomics or or dear Hank and John
that's I'm terrified well that's the
question future what was the question
from Katy there was a question from Katy
let me do Katy asked dear Hank and John
around the time we started college I did
something to my best friend that was a
very selfish and unkind
we MAME Brett we remained friends too
despite this but eventually my guilt
took over and I began to distance myself
to the point where we no longer speak
it's been several years now and based on
social media it seems like she is in a
good place in her life I would like to
believe that I could finally be the
friend she deserves so I decided to
reach out by sharing something that we
both used to find humorous but she has
yet to respond I would like to try again
with something more sincere but I worry
that bringing the past me back into her
life would be selfish and harmful am I I
am wondering I'm wondering is it
actually unkind to interject myself and
apologize in this situation or is it
worth it for another
at a once great friendship that's a good
question and I think that probably it
differs on specifics but in general I
would say that it is never wrong to
apologize as long as you do not ask for
or expect a response yes in fact what I
would say is that it it is probably a
helpful thing to let your friend know
that you recognize that you did a thing
wrong the reason why you retracted is
not because you don't like her but
because you didn't like yourself and
what you had done and just let them know
that and say that that is the thing you
are letting them know not that is a a
overture for a rekindled friendship
right I think that you know you need to
let her make that decision yeah did I
ever tell you about the time that my
college girlfriend got back in touch
with me who's a lovely person I don't
want it I don't want to speak it with
her so but we didn't speak for seven
years and then she emailed me and she
said I thought you would find this book
interesting Dear John I thought you
would find this book interesting signed
her name mm-hmm and I was like you're
kidding me right just that's it like we
didn't talk for eight years and then you
just saw a book on Amazon and you were
like oh that reminds me of that guy but
anyway I actually land do a very
productive two hundred you know what
that book was I do I do remember it yeah
kid it could it be one of the sponsors
of this day's podcast no it's it's a
really dark personal weirdly intimate
right yeah um this this episode of dear
Hank and John is brought to you by
weirdly dark personal things where the
dark personal things not discussed on
this podcast dear Hank and John is also
brought to you by the letter T the
letter T only appearing in the word
hygienist once this episode of dear Hank
and John is brought to you by dumb cow
football club six times worse than AFC
Wimbledon
and of course this episode of dear Hank
and John is brought to you by the
question from Kyrgyzstan
that we are going to answer now we said
we were gonna we're gonna do it we're
very excited this is one of the best
questions I have to say that I have ever
seen not just on this podcast but ever i
I am fascinated by this question I feel
like we should devote several episodes
to it but instead we're just going to
try our best answer it um I said this
person's name wrong earlier I think I
don't know how to pronounce it I think
it's Grell from kyrgyzstan Dear John and
Hank yesterday my teacher asked which
one of you would like to own a Ferrari
then everyone raised their hand then he
asked but what if you knew that everyone
else in the world also had a Ferrari and
almost everyone put their hands down
this got me to thinking about you and by
you I mean people from the West you
often refer to countries as developed
and developing which to me sounds as if
you're hoping that one day we'll all be
quote unquote developed but how is that
even possible sure you could probably
make it so that everyone in the world
had food to eat and didn't die from
preventable diseases but other than that
there is absolutely no way for everyone
in the world to have the same quality of
life as you do in the West and some
countries in East Asia of course I mean
who is going to be sewing the clothes
and making the mobile phones sure lead
to demand for those things will
dramatically increase if every country
is developed but there won't be any way
to get cheap labor anymore I'm sorry if
this question sounds as if I'm not I'm
sorry if this question sounds as if I'm
putting blame on anyone I'm really not I
just don't understand that is a great
question yes it is kind of the question
of modern economics so like panic or not
the optimists response to this question
is that the the overall size of the pie
right can increase and so while there
remains you know people with smaller
slices exactly so while there remains
economic inequality the overall size of
the pie can increase and we have seen
this with hundreds of millions of people
emerging from poverty in the last thirty
years mostly in China and Brazil and
India countries that have you know
developed dramatically but what we mean
when we talk about quote
quote emerging from poverty often means
going you know from a place where you
are in that extreme poverty that girl's
writing about where you you know you
don't have food security and and and you
know people often die of preventable
diseases to going to a place where
you're making ten dollars a day instead
of two dollars a day or one dollar a day
and that's not what we would think of in
the West as you know middle class or as
a you know or even working-class we
would think of that as poverty yes yeah
and there there there are a number of
big questions here I mean we start out
with the question of whether want like
whether one thing something necessary
Nessa Tate's
inequality because you only want the
things that you can't have and if
everybody could have it then you
wouldn't want it even if it were just
like you know if it were a you go you
wouldn't want a Ferrari if every person
had a Ferrari who cares mm-hmm just like
you know now like it used to be a luxury
item to have a refrigerator in America
and it no longer is right the
refrigerator example was actually the
example that I that I would use in terms
of what I think about with development I
do think that we can live in a world
where everyone has a refrigerator yes I
think that would dramatically increase
quality of life for billions of people
and I think that is a good goal mm-hmm I
I think that living your life in a way
that requires or necessitates an
underclass is very problematic and that
almost everyone in the West lives their
life that way including you and me yeah
you yeah including you and me yeah same
thing with my original and the and the
hope is that there is a future in which
those products can be created without
without unnecessary underclass right I
mean a little bit that is the hope I
mean I think that's a very optimistic
hope I think that like anytime all
you're pinning all of your hopes on sort
of mere capitalism right if anytime
you're pinning your Apes only on the
market I think that you or maybe being
too optimistic about what markets can do
but not just what they can do but
what they chew that they tend to do yeah
what they're tend to do is they tend to
put a lot of money in a few hands yeah
and yeah and that's true I mean I don't
want to sound like a Marxist but my
buddy who has seen it happen but Marx
was a good and interesting political
economist so I mean I look I think that
we do when you say like sure you could
probably make it so everyone in the
world had food to eat and didn't die
from preventable diseases like let's
just stop there and say yes let's do
that
yeah I think that that is a that is a
good goal I remember being in when I was
in Ethiopia with the CEO of the Gates
Foundation's who Desmond Hellman I think
is her name I said you know this is so
complicated like I feel overwhelmed by
the complexity of the problem of poverty
I feel overwhelmed by how how do you
address the infrastructure problems how
do you address you know access bit
access to things like better seeds so
that the corn is as high as it is in
Indiana where I live and not you know
coming up to my knee how it like I don't
have I don't have any idea how to fix
any of this and it is completely
overwhelming and like I think rotavirus
vaccines are great but I am totally
overwhelmed and she said to me she said
to me you just jumped over something
that I think is very important which is
that rotavirus vaccines will save a
hundred thousand lives of kids under the
age of five in the next 10 years and
that's a hundred thousand mothers who
don't have to bury their children and I
I think you know I think we and the West
need to do a better job of listening to
people in the really in the poor world
in Ethiopia when they ask us what they
need what they want you know what what
their goals are for their lives and what
what the number one thing that I heard
was clean water and I want my kids to
live and get an education and so those
are my those are my development goals is
to listen better and then and then
respond but I also think it's really
interesting to hear from I mean
Kyrgyzstan is a middle-income
with what we would call in like
development like a middle-income country
it's very interesting to hear that
perspective because a lot of times we
don't write anyway it's a great question
that I don't have a great answer for
obviously I don't know if you do Hank I
just talked a lot I think I talked as
much as I could
it's all I had do you want to move on to
the news from Mars and AFC one a little
yeah I'm still I'm still I'm still gonna
mulling this question I feel like we
should I feel like we should start a new
podcast called questions from grill this
one person asks us really interesting
questions anyway thank you for listening
oh wait right we have to do the NART new
dinars from mousse and AFC mumble -
sounds great
and this week's Mars news our Mars Narda
psychology I call it Nora's mousse and
this week's NARS moves yeah scientists
have done a lot of research on how Mars
became not wonderful
okay the last good place for people
let's do yeah let's take another step
back and just celebrate how much better
Earth is than Mars yeah period
oh man stop yes definitely is there a
way that Mars is better than Earth no no
no I mean you could you could say that
there there are ways in which it
outranks us and like just sort of just
mass no I mean it doesn't it's smaller
than Earth but but colder colder yeah
yeah this book called do you love winter
do you love Mars do you hate there being
too many atoms in the atmosphere have
you ever wanted to like jump but wish
that you couldn't jump quite as high
yeah you could jump higher on Mars Damon
I just told you it was less massive and
that it had west of an atmosphere yeah
well that's the ethic the thickness of
the atmosphere does it really hold you
back that much a little bit a little
good buzz from going all the way out
[Applause]
yeah I know it does if I were on Mars
correct me if I'm wrong and I jumped
like
like if I I mean obviously I don't have
great quad muscles but like if I had
better if I was better at jumping it
would be easier for me to leave
Mars's you know orbit yeah that right
it'd be easier for me to leave Mars than
Earth right well yes because of gravity
but if I wanted to get you know even
that's that's almost all because of
gravity but but I will tell you how you
are right okay if there was a ball the
size of of Mars yeah that had the
Earth's atmosphere yeah would be harder
to jump off of that planet than it would
be to jump off of Mars right because
there's more atmosphere to push through
right so it's overwhelmingly a better
place to play basketball as long as you
have a respirator I get a full spacesuit
yes why do we talk about it I mean well
one of the reasons Mars is the worst is
because once upon a time it had a nice
thick atmosphere yeah but it no longer
does and the reason for that is the Sun
the Sun is great yeah it is a nice thing
for us to have here on earth Australia
in favor I would mostly not exist
without it though it would a little bit
the deep sea vents and such but Mars
Mars's atmosphere was ionized and blown
away by the by energy from the Sun and
this happens on earth and it continues
to happen on Mars but it happens less on
earth because we have a strong magnetic
field uh-huh and there is there's a
belief that Mars probably used to have a
magnetic field and thus was able to hold
on to its atmosphere and then when it's
met me that field stopped it lost its
atmosphere and we have now been able to
model quite accurately what what what
exactly happened to Mars is atmosphere
and it's a bummer man it's too bad so
quick question yeah is our atmosphere
going to blow away if the magnetic field
stops which is that gonna happen no no I
mean potentially in billions of years oh
I'm not worried about that we don't even
know if thousands of years let's get to
the news from AFC Wimbledon let's
celebrate what really matters yeah so
right because we are only going to be
here for a little while and all of the
things that we learn about Mars while we
are here will be rendered irrelevant by
our endeavor
bull non-existence as a species and so
will all the gore goals we have scored
in soccer matches but that does not not
matter because both of those things
matter to us
they matter now they matter to us which
is the only kind of mattering and in
incredibly exciting news the AFC
Wimbledon you might remember the last
podcast I talked about how they're going
to be playing Portsmouth a team that was
once recently in the Premier League but
then got demoted a bunch of times due to
going bankrupt and is now owned by its
fans but they still have incredible
support I don't know if you know the
saying Portsmouth is actually it's a
town in England it is and has a port in
the mouth of a river no incorrect it is
called Portsmouth because it is the
place where port the liquor was invented
oh and the mouth is where you drink it
really no no it's because it's at the
mouth of a river um it's because it's a
port city because I was like I'm pretty
sure port must have been expended
somewhere where there was a port no no
it's total coincidence port is just it's
an anagram and drop which is the kind of
grape you use to make portion that is
correct you don't have to look it up I
promise don't even bother going to
Wikipedia I'm quite sure you can just
Google or twine yes I'm right we played
Portsmouth and it's a Portuguese
fortified one port it is from these
channel it's report Jugal yes vino de
porto of you know de port Oh interesting
alright so it has nothing to do with
ports then accept the portugal has a
bunch of them probably iesous deriving
all of all of portugal which is which is
portuguese for poor land of ports
[Laughter]
portugal which according according to
spain has all of spain sports okay right
hey guys so the news from of mars neva
right so the news room AFC wimbledon is
this
we played portsmouth who at the time
were third in the table and do you know
what happened Hank can you imagine the
most dramatic outcome to a football game
yes what would it be at the at the 89th
minute yes the ball yes
into the goal area yes bounces off the
post
yes bounces off someone's foot yes
ounces off the post again bounces off
the back of the goalies head yeah that's
not what happened it was in Neil Neil
draw there was a nil nil draw for AFC
Wimbledon against Portsmouth but that's
great that's a good point away from a
home against the team who's higher up in
the table so now we're ninth instead of
10th we are currently ninth in the table
more importantly AFC Wimbledon Hank
you'll remember the Dons trust owns the
team every every fan of AFC Wimbledon is
an equal owner of the team and so on in
on big decisions we all vote together so
we all needed to vote to sell the
current stadium to Chelsea so that we
can afford to buy or to build the new
stadium that we want to build in the
historic home of Wimbledon Football Club
so we have completed that last vote it
has succeeded so once we get planning
permission and the money to build the
new stadium we will also get the money
for selling the old stadium the stadium
where we currently play and that was a
vital part of this long-term plan to
hopefully by 2018 be playing in a
state-of-the-art fan owned stadium in
the heart of the Wimbledon community so
that was a big big deal the the votes
passed it's all done except now we need
planning permission from the council the
local council there and then we're gonna
need to raise just a small amount of ten
million dollars I have a question yeah
absolutely as a fan owned a team yes
what would happen yeah if AFC wimbledon
due to the weirdness of the world yeah
in ten years or so or is is throwing off
a billion dollars in profit a year would
you give some of that mmm I mean I don't
think so I don't this is so far from
ever being a concern
ever heard a single Wimbledon fan
discussed the possibility yeah my
understanding is that if a AFC Wimbledon
were making a billion dollar profit that
billion dollars would be invested back
into the team or the community so AFC
Wimbledon also has a foundation where a
percentage of their money goes you know
to support local charities and other
initiatives so it might go to the
foundation I don't think that it would
go to me however I am ready to see that
day when there may be that billion
dollar profit by the way other other
football clubs that don't make a profit
include Manchester United Liverpool
Football Club yeah so I think it's
pretty pretty far down the road that
we've got to worry too much about making
money all right
well John this was a wonderful day on
dear Hank and John what did we learn
well we've learned that Hygienist omega1
t we learned that John Green has had
more hands in his mouth than any other
human on earth according to John Green
we learned that globalization and
development and and Ferrari acquisitions
are extremely complicated and that
anybody who claims to have absolute
certainty about any of it is probably
lying and we learned that your
anniversary is not a competition but you
should start planning several months in
in business but you know what it is I
mean they do keep score and there is a
winner at the end right whoever's around
longest oh it always ends in death here
at dear Hank and John thanks for
listening to our podcast if you want to
ask us questions you can do so at Hank
and John at gmail.com thanks to
everybody who sent in questions this
week I'm sorry that there were so many
good ones and too few to get to but
that's always the case and what else do
we say at the end here Hank you can find
us on a Hank you can find us on Twitter
at Hank green or John Green this podcast
is edited by Nicholas Jenkins I can't
believe that you just missed an
opportunity to promote your own snaps my
snapchat is that Hank Tre
music is from gunnarolla and as they say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]